west palm beach is just a place that is
home to me it's where it all started i
remember
when i was just going in and just group
trying to have fun when you're just
young
you have a dream and it's just like just
trying to achieve whatever you can do
so you just went outside late at night
going to the park trying to go who
trying to go around
[Music]
you gotta start with this acai bowl yeah
yeah i'm eating healthy now yeah
i'm turning big sad [ __ ] i say well
as you can see the strawberries with
bananas
i think that's oats and they got a
little bit of honey in it
this fire you know it's been my go-to
it's pretty good though
no cap looking
growing up my mom raised me by herself
she always tried to do stuff for
me and my two brothers and one sister to
see how hard she works
that pushes me you just want to help
your family out
give back to them because they put so
much time and effort into you
people just ask me what what's my dream
is like as a kid you know you always
have to have a dream
i just grew up watching basketball so
it's always been a dream mom
one of my proudest achievements was
winning my first gold medal u-16
i feel like it opened up a lot for me it
was me james wiseman vernon carey
jaylen green jaylen suggs i never
expected that in my life so
it was just crazy to me people started
looking at me more so blowing up after
that there's parks now
down the lane and it goes and he just is
so long he elongates to the rim there in
the open court
into that system i knew that was the
right fit for me that's when i watched
the program
things that it wanted me to do talks
with coaches i already knew
what it was from the jump so that just
allowed me to go in there
be who i am that's what you're talking
about right there scotty parts
during the season it was i would say it
was very different one of your teammates
get covered
and then you got to sit out two weeks
you can't play a game
that was very weird you know it's just
like your eyes on your toes
scotty first came out to santa barbara
and we got in the gym to kind of
evaluate his game and where he's at
the first thing you know we had done
ahead of time was go over film and kind
of prepare for him and
his ability to be you know a big point
forward and be able to
just create for everybody else is so
obvious
i'm just trying to make the right play
each and every time so if the play is
open
i'm trying to find that play and see
what's the right decision to make
the big thing we wanted to really work
on you know further developing is his
jump shot and his confidence in it he's
just such a pass first guy
that it's getting him to understand like
sometimes the best option is him taking
that shot
full extension full extension full
extension
yes sir i like packing cool fun dude
nice guy to talk to as well
taught me a lot about my shot i helped
me get my general feeling from where i'm
starting from
to where i'm going just helping me get
better setting the number for him or
giving him hey we're trying to go five
out of seven
or three for five or seven out of ten
you know just giving him a goal
uh he's a competitor so he always rises
to the occasion and and
wants to go until he can get it let's go
look at the boys look at the boys peek
through boys right there boys right
there
make it down
hey guys what's up we're at 50 right now
he's about to
get the arm shoulders right i think his
arm day
so everybody here about to meet the crew
i mean the idea behind p3 was that we
could collect
more data on athletes we could have them
have this interaction with technology
that would give us information about how
these guys move how their bodies work
how their systems are put together so we
can take better care
and so when we assess an athlete like
scotty barnes
we compare his system to all the
physical systems that he's going to be
competing against
in the mba develop my muscles at p3 you
know we just been training working on
different things
helping me jump better not doing so much
to
try to get ourselves big and strong but
just to maintain like yeah and make us
feel good
that's why i like it i feel like after
p3 can just go hoop on the court
they keep us right we've had scotty for
three years now pretty much all these
top young players find their way to p3
before they get to the nba now
and so we can track their not just their
how their physical system looks at one
point in time
but we can track their development cycle
scotty is a really good athlete
these last two years he's made huge
gains like much steeper
growth curve than most of our young
athletes and this time when we assessed
him
his drop vertical was the second highest
we'd ever measured with comps from
almost
900 nba players that we've assessed the
second highest jump ever
like that's it was phenomenal
scott i'll give you five bucks if you
eat that one i didn't know what that
is i'll give you 10. well i don't know
what that means though
what is that twenty twenty dollars i'll
give you twenty dollars
i'm not about to feed you no i'm gonna
smell it
oh she's terrible how do you do that
i'll give you 20 bucks if you eat this i
can't i'm i'm bad at trying new foods
yeah grandma's family we like cousins to
be honest
we look though she bought man on this
like man
he bit i like it let's go good defense
kd
there was four people guarding this man
when he tried to bring it up in
transition
come on man that's how you know he's
like that bro
don't set a double down screen for kd
that's a tough guard
enough cover
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me i just want to win games if i need to
play power forward
help my team get rebounds push the
transition that's what i do
if i need to bother my hands to create
look for people get shooters involved
things like that
be a slasher whatever is needed that's
what i'm willing to do
to try to win basketball games i see
scotty's role in the nba evolving
really right on point with the times
right he's positionless so
scotty really fits with today's nba and
the ability to be
anywhere and everywhere at the same time
if you take a guy that has
the work ethic that scotty has and you
give him the right
blueprint to get better then you know
he's gonna just keep going whatever
fan base it is you know i'm just gonna
come in working
hard from day one i'm gonna come in with
the right mindset right approach
i feel like it's gonna be a good vibe
you know i'm gonna have fun
they're gonna have fun in the crowd it's
gonna be a perfect combination
of course it's gonna be a pretty special
moment it's gonna be one of the biggest
moments of my life
everything that i've been working for i
don't know if i'll cry
i'm probably gonna scream let's go
still got a long way to go it ain't over
yet i feel like it's just one step
a big part of it you're getting there
but you gotta do things to stay there
you can't just get there and think it's
over you guys
way more of the journey that we got to
go i just want to leave that legacy that
scotty barnes was one of those guys that
was just a different type
a guy that studied the game that i did
whatever i could
you